ta parole est un monsieur pierre
lellouche merci monsieur le président
monsieur mise de l'intérieur beaucoup de
français sont heureux de voir arriver là
en france le championnat d'europe de
football
l'un des événements sportifs les plus
importants de la planète et beaucoup se
préparent à vivre cet événement comme
une fête mais au vu des évènements
extrêmement graves qui ont été constatés
samedi dernier au stade de france à
l'occasion de la coupe de la finale de
la coupe de france
il ne faudrait pas que la fête tourne au
drame
à l'occasion ici même du débat jeudi sur
la prorogation de l'état d'urgence qu'on
collègue philippe dugoujon et moi même
nous vous avons fortement indiqué que
compte tenu des pressions exercées sur
nos forces de police par l'euro bien sûr
mais aussi par le terroriste et
mouvements sociaux etc terrain il
n'était pas raisonnable pour les
pouvoirs publics d'ériger des fans zone
dans les grandes villes de france
surtout dans des endroits emblématiques
comme la tour eiffel avec tous les soirs
92 mille personnes derrière un grillage
et nous vous avons demandé d'organiser
ses fans zone dans des lieux mieux
protégés dans des stades
or samedi dernier il s'est passé des
choses très graves au stade de france
toutes sortes d'objets interdits ont été
introduits dans le stade des feux ondes
et allumer des spectateurs ont témoigné
que les faux ils n'étaient pas
respectées et le préfet de
seine-saint-denis lui-même qui avait mis
en place un système de sécurité inédit a
dû constater publiquement qu'il avait je
cite cd alors dans ces conditions pour
les moins inquiétante vous en
conviendrez monsieur le ministre je
voudrais vous poser calmement la
question suivant en souhaitant que vous
y répondiez calmement sans vous énervez
sans faire de mauvaises politiques sans
démagogie éhontée comment comptez vous
remédier aux failles béantes révélé
samedi vers
et pensez vous continuer avec cette fan
zone à paris qui est un risque majeur
pour la sécurité mais ne gagez bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député le loup je réponds
toujours calmement notamment à vos
questions parce que elles sont toujours
posés avec une extrême amabilité et
lorsque les questions sont ainsi posées
il n'y a aucune raison d'y répondre
autrement que s'est-il passé samedi
samedi
monsieur le président à l'occasion du
match qui s'est tenue au stade de france
un certain nombre de problèmes sont
apparus premier élément sur lequel je
voudrais insister
l'organisation de ce match n'était pas
dans la configuration qui prévaudra au
moment de l'euro 2016 des organisateurs
ne sont pas les mêmes des dispositifs de
sécurité qui ont été mises en oeuvres
n'étaient pas les mêmes ne sont pas les
mêmes que ceux que nous mobiliserons
mais en revanche les dysfonctionnements
qui ont été constatés doivent être
prises en compte pour l'organisation de
l'euro 2016
pourquoi y at il eu ces
dysfonctionnements il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements parce que le nombre
d'entrées et de zones de près filtrage
qui ont été mises en oeuvre à l'occasion
de ce match n'était pas suffisante
ce qui a posé un problème de fluidité
des entrées ce qui a posé un problème
d'efficacité des contrôles constatant
que les structures qui était en charge
de la sécurité dans le stade et
notamment la fédération française de
football n'avait pas signalé
correctement les entrées et n'avait pas
rempli les obligations qui étaient les
leurs j'ai réuni l'ensemble des
organisateurs
hier trois réunions ont eu lieu avec
l'ensemble des organisateurs de manière
arba leye l'ensemble du dispositif de
sécurité pour atteindre trois objectifs
fluidité des entrées fouilles efficace
et palpation de sécurité et
troisièmement fluidité des sorties le
dispositif à partir du retour
d'expérience et des préconisations
d'hier sera totalement revu j'ai demandé
au préfet de zone que j'ai convoqués
hier
de bien vouloir superviser l'ensemble du
dispositif dans chaque ville et je me
suis entretenu avec alain juppé hier
soir et nous sommes convenus ensemble
compte tenu de ces monsieurs mise